- Welcome to this
panel, which is called
Ways of Knowing the City.
And we have three speakers.
I'll tell you a bit
about them in a moment.
And we have a dynamic format,
which I'll also explain.
But first, a little bit
about the topic, affect
and experience and a rich
array of sensory information
will always be essential
parts of knowing a city.
Modern media and the city
are closely intertwined.
Film is like the
kinetics of experience
in the city with its new
forms of modern transport.
Photography is like a glimpse,
a vignette, a framed moment.
In the 19th century, French
poet Charles Baudelaire imagined
the persona of a
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
a stroller, or someone who
walked the city in order
to experience it and to take in
fleeting expressions and to be
simultaneously part of
and apart from the crowd.
And these observations would
be social and aesthetic.
So Baudelaire's
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] has had
a long after-life as a figure
for urban life and even
for modernity itself.
And the [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
anticipates street photography
and even tourism.
Cities function as keepers of
cultural and historical memory
as well.
Scholar Andreas
Huyssen posits cities
as palimpsests of history,
incarnation of time in stone,
sites of memory extending
both in time and space.
And Italo Calvino, in
his novel from 1972,
Invisible Cities
wrote that quote,
"the city does
not tell its past,
but contains it like the
lines of a hand written
in the corners of the streets,
the gratings of the windows,
the banisters of the steps, the
antennae of the lightning rods,
the poles of the flags,
every segment marked
in turn with scratches,
indentations, and scrolls."
Our understanding
of city environments
will always be intertwined with
the development of literature,
film, photography, and newer
media as artistic modes.
Today, in this
first panel, we will
ask how we can connect these
nuanced humanistic perspectives
and their document
of human experience
with new forms of
media and big data that
investigate the modern
urban experience
and produce new
forms of knowledge
using powerful new tools
and conceptual paradigms.
How do the non-human
and the human
intersect in urban
environments today?
Collectively, we'll try
to make some headway
on this topic in panel one.
This panel lasts in total
for an hour and a half.
First, we'll have presentations
about 15 minutes each
from our three speakers who are
in the order in which they'll
present, Heidi Ewing
who is a filmmaker
and co-director of the Emmy
awarding film Detropia,
a documentary about
the contemporary state
of her hometown, Detroit,
which premiered at the Sundance
festival in 2012.
Mark Shepard, professor of
architecture and media studies
from the University of Buffalo,
a practitioner and a theorist
who explores in his
work the complex notion
of the sentient city.
We tend to think of
people as being sentient,
but in fact cities can be.
And finally, Sooni Taraporevela,
the photographer, screenwriter,
and director.
And her photography
exhibition Home
in the City, Bombay
1976 to Mumbai 2016
is currently showing at
the Whitworth Gallery
in Manchester,
England and has been
listed as one of the top five
art exhibitions in the United
Kingdom by The Guardian.
So after the panelists have
completed their presentations,
I will moderate a short
discussion among them
for about 15 minutes.
And then we'll
have a Q&A session
where members of
the audience can
come to the mic that will
be in the central aisle
and ask questions of the
presenters themselves.
So with no further ado, I
suggest that we get started.
And I invite Heidi
Ewing to the podium
to give her presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much.
Well, thank you to
Liz, and to Radcliffe,
and everyone here for
taking an interest
in cities and urbanism.
I think it's funny
that Angela mentioned
the need for confessions
when we talk about cities.
It's very true about Detroit.
So my confession, I actually
grew up 20 minutes north
of Detroit.
It's very important.
And my father was a Detroiter.
And my parents were part of
the so-called white flight out
of Detroit after the
uprisings, riots,
however you'd like
to call it, in 1967.
My granny, from the
north side of Detroit,
refused to leave till
she couldn't get up
her stairs at the end.
Her body gave out.
She used to proudly call
herself the last white lady
on the block.
That's my confession.
So has a documentary director,
I make a living following
the stories of real people
and, with my camera,
capturing the change.
And, well, you hope
there's going to change
and evolutions over
a period of time.
And what I've learned
in my career so far
is that narratives are
very, very powerful.
A narrative is a powerful tool.
In the film Detropia, which
is one of my films from 2012,
I had the chance to
chronicle the narrative
of an entire place or
attempt to chronicle
the narrative of an
entire place, which
would be the city of Detroit.
And during the
production of this film,
something unexpected happened.
Before my eyes, the
conversation about Detroit
completely changed.
From the time I began
shooting the film in 2009
to its theatrical
release in 2012,
the local narrative,
meaning the story
that the Detroit residents
themselves told themselves
about their city, began to clash
with the national narrative,
which by that I mean the way in
which outsiders and the media
chose to see the city.
And this sort of happened,
I guess, by coincidence
while we were making the film.
So I'd like to start with
the Time Magazine cover.
So this was 2009.
This was when I
began to Detropia.
Soon after this, Time Magazine
published the cover story,
"The Tragedy of Detroit."
The article described
Detroit as a place that
looked as if it had quote,
"been savaged by a hurricane
or submerged by a
ravenous flood," unquote.
Why hadn't the world
noticed, the article asked.
To me, who grew up in
the Detroit Metro area,
Time was simply
mimicking what we
had been shouting for years,
what we knew all along.
Segregation, racial
inequality, subpar education,
massive governmental corruption
at the local level, an auto
industry that had refused to
change, a city that refused
to diversify, crime was
wild, jobs had vanished,
we knew these things already.
The article was not a shock.
But the nation seemed shocked
as this got a lot of attention.
This Time Magazine cover, there
was a lot of recoverage on it.
But the interesting
thing is we locals,
we Detroiters and
Metro Detroiters--
my father was in manufacturing,
so was very close
to our hearts, what was
happening to Detroit--
we had another narrative, a
counter-narrative perhaps,
that we told about our own city.
And that was one very
close to our hearts.
And it was a story of deep pride
in Detroit's place in history.
To us, in symbolic
terms at the very least,
Detroit was the most
important place in America.
And when I started
shooting Detropia,
I found that that
narrative was still alive.
And so I'd like to show
you a clip from the film.
This is one of my
subjects, George McGregor,
President of United
Auto Workers Local 22.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- During World War
II, America was
like, wow, we built war
machines for the world, right?
Right over here, where
[INAUDIBLE] in Fleetwood,
they turned that from
an automobile factory
to building airplanes
right there on 4th Street.
We built everything.
We put them on a
ship and shipped them
to England and everywhere.
Y'all know what we did.
Keep up with that history.
Now, we can't even
buy American made
washing machine or an iron.
So where did our
manufacturing base go?
Where did it all go?
Because we built everything.
We built everything,
everything, America did.
We have a standard
of living in America
that the working guy provided
a standard of living,
which is eroding now.
But it's a standard of
living that the working guy,
and it started right
here in Detroit.
Right here in Detroit, a middle
class started right here.
Everybody knows.
We just got to face
up to it, so we're
able to send our kids to school.
We're able to set up
a little bit of money.
Some of our guys
were able enough
to get a little place
of north or whatever.
It's middle class, got a boat.
You understand what I'm saying?
Middle class.
Leave it to Beaver, the white
house, the picket fence.
Leave it to Beaver, wasn't
that the middle class?
Come on now.
We're looking at
it on TV, right?
Weren't we?
Do Then we see it
come into our lives.
There it is, the middle class.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I love that guy,
George McGregor.
What a way to synthesize the
feelings that a lot of us
have and a lot of
Detroiters still
have about the place and
the importance of Detroit.
You know, hearkening
back to Angela's talk,
you know, he is a product
of the great migration.
His family was from
the south and came up
to work in the
factories, he included.
And the black middle
class, he's evidence of it.
Anyway, my parents
and grandparents
all sounded like George.
Detroit's role in the creation
of the middle class lifestyle
should be honored and cherished.
This narrative acted as a type
of urban institutional memory
shared by natives of the city.
But what I found most
surprising while making Detropia
is that this strong connection
to history, which we don't find
that very often in
20-somethings right now,
but this strong
connection to history
was still prevalent even
among the youngest Detroiters
I met who had never
experienced not
even a moment of this heyday
that we always, always heard
about.
Even for them, Detroit
remained thick with nostalgia
for the elusive past.
And I'd never seen people
in their 20s feel so old
and talk so old and have such a
grasp and nostalgia for an era
that they never lived.
And that I found over and
over while making Detropia.
And that brings us to
Crystal and how she
interacted with her own city.
She was in her mid
20s when we met her.
She was born and
raised in Detroit.
She was one of the residents
that could easily have left,
but had chosen to stay.
And all the characters
in the film Detropia
could have left, that we
focus on, and chose to stay.
And that's very significant.
But the city had too
much of a grip on her.
And the past had too much of a
grip on her for her to leave.
And she used to go when
she wasn't waiting tables,
she would do urban explorations.
And she would break
into old buildings
and try to figure
out who lived there
and what life had been like.
So I'd like to show Crystal
[INAUDIBLE] from Detropia.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- July 4, 2010,
Independence Day.
I'm going real revolutionary.
We're in a beautiful building.
History is just one of my
things even since grade school.
That's a passion.
What was there?
Who was there?
These hallways, though-- I mean,
I'm picturing this place clean
and there being-- you
know, people walking around
and shit happening.
Bring that shit
on up here, girl.
Wow.
It's amazing where you see where
they just ripped out the wall.
Because there's copper
piping right there.
Can you imagine like having
breakfast right here?
You know what I mean?
Like, look at your view.
Look at your view
in the morning.
Like, yeah, I'm going
to go out and conquer
the world, because I can damn
near see it from right here.
Motown right up the street.
We can't leave, man,
can't fucking leave.
I feel like I was maybe
here a little while back,
or I'm older than I
really am, but I just
have this young body
and spirit and mind.
But I have the memory of this
place when it was banging.
That's how I feel.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So So I found people
like Crystal over
and over again while
making Detropia
that were haunted by
the past, something
I didn't expect to find
when making the film.
Crystal had every
reason to believe
that she was the last
person on Earth that
was interested in all these
empty blocks of her city,
but that assumption
was very wrong.
As we know, the
2008 market crash
landed plenty of
young college grads
back in their parents
basements, maybe
in some of your basements.
But
Rumors of $500 houses,
large lofts for artists,
and quasi-lawless city
in search of residents
sounded pretty appealing
to some people.
The newcomers, who are mostly
young single and white,
came with no malice to Detroit.
Yet, they also came with
little to no appreciation
or understanding
of Detroit's past,
including its very
charged racial past.
They preferred to talk
about the new trendy ideas
like large scale urban farming,
which was a major idea being
floated in Detroit or
to start microbreweries
or graphic design firms.
They were not
interested in pondering
all that had been lost before.
They were not haunted
by the past of Detroit.
Detroit gained 14,000
white residents
between 2010 and 2014.
It was the first uptick
like that in 60 years.
This attitude that
a lot of them had,
which was that Detroit was a
blank slate or an empty canvas,
this idea crept in.
Detroit was almost
their Petri dish
for experimentation
of all kinds.
The new narrative
was that Detroit
could be almost a
playground for young whites.
And they could live
cheaply and well.
And here's an example of that.
These are two
artists that we met
that are in the film Detropia,
Steve and Dorota Coy.
This is sort of just after they
moved into the city, the Coy's
Detropia, please.
- Dorota and I met in Hawaii.
We knew we weren't
going to stay in Hawaii.
And so we were just
tossing around places.
We wanted to be somewhere
urban, of course.
We had a project
that we wanted to do,
like street art,
public installation.
And so we just
started evaluating.
We looked at Baltimore.
We were looking
into New York City.
And Detroit came up.
And I knew that's
one thing Detroit
had an abundance of was
space and old warehouses.
I feel like we've assimilated
into that community of artists
that are moving here
and coming here.
That's pretty sweet.
I've never had
appliances this nice,
so I feel like I should
be taking care of them.
Yeah.
We bought just a
couple of weeks ago.
And we're able to keep our
studio, because everything
is so affordable.
Detroit is constantly
amazing me.
I feel like it's redefining
what the value of things are.
You know, $25,000
for an amazing loft?
I don't know.
That just makes it
accessible to people like me.
I would never be able to afford
to own a home as an artist.
And here I am with a
studio and an apartment
in a major city functioning
for like $700 or less a month.
We can experiment here.
Because if we fail, we haven't
really fallen anywhere.
- So you see the
difference in the newcomers
and the old timers there.
You know, at first,
Detroiters reacted
with curiosity and
skepticism at the newcomers
and their embrace of this new
Detroit that they could see.
And there was some
humorous headlines.
My favorite headline was
from the Detroit Metro
Times that was reacting
to these carpetbaggers.
And it said, "Major Cities
Unloading Undesirable Hipsters
in Detroit."
Can I see the billboard
Bushwick, please?
And you know, this was sort
of a little advertising.
This is in Bushwick,
New York in Brooklyn.
It's like, you're
going to be a hipster
and have a hipster's life?
You can live cheaper and
better if you come to Detroit.
There was also this graffiti
campaign "move to Detroit,"
which you would
see on the bridges.
This was not a massive campaign.
But it goes to show sort
of this looking at Detroit
in a completely different way.
And suddenly, it sort
of had a street cred.
A lot of New York Times
articles and the like
were obsessed with these
young white newcomers,
endless articles about them.
And what were they doing there?
And would they
help save the city,
and all of that sort of thing.
So there's this
comeback narrative
of Detroit started to arise.
And it's really interesting,
because the corporations really
soon followed all
of this coverage.
In 2011, just as Detroit
entered bankruptcy proceedings,
Shinola, the fancy
watch and bike company,
set up shop in the city.
Their pitch was that
by purchasing a $550
watch or a $3,000
bicycle, hip consumers
could buy into the revival
of one of America's
great industrial cities.
So corporations and investors
really heard the call.
Dan Gilbert, the owner of the
Cleveland Cavaliers and Quicken
Loans, began to scoop up a
lot of these skyscrapers that
had been long emptied and
filled them with luxury lofts.
In 2013, Whole
Foods came to town
and was greeted with
a full-fledged frenzy.
The city had arrived.
Whole Foods was there.
So the rebranding of
Detroit's national narrative
had been sort of complete.
But had the city actually
improve, and for whom?
And who does this
revitalization benefit?
Well, here are the facts,
just facts, just numbers.
Detroit has been
number one on Forbes
most dangerous cities list
now for four years in a row.
Detroit only has enough
jobs to employ roughly 37%
of the population.
The public school
remains in a disgrace.
On the whole, black
residents which
make up over 80% of
the city have not
benefited from this new Detroit.
A very small area called
midtown in the downtown area,
you see restaurants,
you see galleries,
you see more tourists.
You do see an economy
coming through here.
But the rest of the
140 square miles
remains exactly as I've
always remembered it
since I was a child.
Detroit declared
bankruptcy in 2013.
Today, still the population
continues to decline.
However, they think that
by 2018 the population,
the endless decline,
might actually bottom out.
And that is significant.
It's not insignificant.
But narratives are powerful.
When I started to
Detropia, people
would ask what I was
working on, I'd say,
I'm spending a lot
of time in Detroit.
And they would always answer,
I'm sorry to hear that.
A snide remark, oh, Detroilet
and things like that.
Now, when I say I'm going back
to Detroit for the weekend,
they say, oh, my god, cool.
I heard it's back now.
And I'm dying to
go check it out.
And maybe that narrative,
the Detroit phoenix
rising from the ashes, will
someday become a reality.
Perhaps, Detroit's
affordability and strange allure
will continue to bring more
people to the city, people
like yourselves, with
good ideas of how
a greater number of
Detroiters can actually
benefit from this new interest
and investment in the city.
We're far off from this, I feel.
But the fascination with
Detroit continues to grow.
And somehow the city
has a hold on us.
In fact, writer
Drew Philips likes
to say Detroit is the most
interesting city on the planet.
Because when you
scratch the surface,
you only find a mirror.
There's just something about
this city, about this story,
we cannot shake.
So I hope you continue
to explore it.
Thank you so much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you first, of
course, to the organizers,
to Eve, to Julie, to Erik,
and naturally to Dean Cohen
supporting for
consistently supporting
what seems to have been
an incredible run here
in the Radcliffe Institute.
I'd like to especially
thank you Eve Blau, who
was the protagonist
in bringing me here
last year to this workshop
on urban intermedia, which
provided an impetus
for me to organize
my thoughts around this issue of
how what we know about the city
is conditioned through the
lens with which we see it
and, subsequently, how that
lens in turn conditions us.
You
It's fortuitous to follow
Heidi, I think, in the sense
that what I'm going to
talk about is in a sense
the other side of what
might be described
as the power of personal
narrative to articulate a place
and how we read a
city through people.
And I think we, in
the keynote, heard
quite a bit about this
notion that people
define cities, which then
in turn define people.
So it's this relationship
that I'm interested in.
And I'm interested
in looking forward
in terms of contemporary
modes of observing
the city, in particular the
role of big data, algorithms,
and so-called intelligent
urban infrastructure
are shaping what we know
about the city today
and how, in turn, it's
beginning to shape us.
And my interest here
lies in questioning
how this reciprocal relationship
between the methods and objects
of urban research changes
when we shift from employing
representational tools by
which the present city is
observed to methods involving
data mining and analysis that
aim to derive observations
and make predictions
about future situations.
So this is primarily a
story about shifting focus
from deploying representational
tools, such as the film
camera as instruments
for recording
or for urban observation,
to instrumenting
physical environments
themselves,
and ultimately the people
that inhabit them with sensors
and software systems to quantify
urban life in ways that claim
to lead to ever more
optimized, efficient,
and sustainable cities.
Now, devices for
observing the world
have been around for a while.
Much has been said about
the camera obscura,
for instance, and its role
in recording geometrically
accurate views of the city.
These are four drawings
by Canaletto representing
the Campa San Giovanni e
Paolo in Venice, produced
with the aid of a
camera obscura resulting
in studies for this painting.
And as historian
[INAUDIBLE] has noted,
the camera obscura
can be understood
not only as a
performative device, which
is to say a tool
for representing
an urban space, for
example, but also
as an epistemological
model that articulates
a relationship between an
observer and the world.
Here, we find the construction
of a monocular subject
isolated and ensconced within
a dark room to which the world
has gathered its image
through a pinhole or oculus
and projected onto
an interior wall
of an observational device.
Now, if we compare this device
with that of the stereoscope,
a different story and a
different observing subject
emerges.
As a byproduct of early
19th century advances
in physiological
optics, the stereoscope
capitalized on the discovery
that with binocular vision,
each eye sees something
slightly differently
due to the angular disparity
existing between them.
The production of depth
in sight was subsequently
understood to be in some way
related to the mind's ability
to unite and reconcile
two dissimilar images.
Within this context,
the stereoscope
was developed to reproduce
this optical experience
mechanically.
Now, significantly, the
device marks an intent
not just to represent
a given space,
but actually to
simulate its presence.
What is sought is not
merely a likeness,
but a lucid tangibility.
With the stereoscope,
one is confronted
not with the view of the world
through an aperture or a frame,
but rather with the
technical reconstitution
of an already reproduced
world fragmented
into two non-identical models.
Through the incorporation
of an observing subject
into the mechanics
of the device,
the stereoscopic image
is subsequently produced.
Now, the body is immobilized and
integrated with the apparatus.
The subject becomes
a participant
in the production
of a verisimilitude
through a process of unifying
and reconciling the experience
of difference.
This junk disjunction between
an experience and its cause
is rarified, the real
conflated with the optical.
Absent is the notion of a point
of view in a Cartesian sense
as might be characterized
by the camera obscura.
There is, in the end,
nothing out there.
So the radical differences
between these pre-cinematic
devices highlight the role of
the apparatus in constituting
not only the parameters of
what we know about the world,
but also how we conceive
our relationship to it,
and ultimately how
we know the world
and locate our agency
to act within it.
Now, fast forward to late 20th
century urban observations
and the work of William Whyte
and his street life project,
which aimed to study how
people behave and interact
within urban environments
and with urban environments
through a structured
research protocol
that aspired to empirical
observations, in this case,
involving time
lapse photography.
This is a photograph of the
apparatus in question, a Super
8 film camera and a clock which
was persistently in the frame.
Now, I'd like to play for you
a short excerpt from his film,
The Social Life of Small
Urban Spaces, which
documents the project and
distills a few observations
from the results.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This is the plaza of this
[INAUDIBLE] building in New
York, late morning.
With a time lapse camera, we
were testing a hypothesis.
The sun, we were
pretty sure, would
be the chief factor
in determining where
people would sit or not sit.
Now, just after 12:00 they begin
to sit right where the sun is.
I was enormously pleased.
What a perfectly
splendid correlation.
It was quite misleading,
as we were to see later.
But it was a very
encouraging way to start.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So this notion,
I want you to hold
on to this notion of
misleading correlations.
What's important here
is that the project
departs from a set of hypotheses
about how people interact
and behave in smaller
spaces and deploys
the filmic apparatus
in a structured way
to test these hypotheses.
This is what we might
characterize today as a small
data study, which is to say
small data being characterized
by their generally
limited volume,
their non-continuous collection,
their narrow . variety,
and usually generated to
answer very specific questions.
You start with a
question about a space,
what people are doing there.
Now, I'd like you to compare
Whyte's apparatus with this.
These are two smartphones
affixed to windows recording
activity happening on a
street outside, In this case,
in Manhattan as well.
And this is a demo clip from
a startup called Placemeter.
Placemeter is a service that
deploys crowdsource smartphones
as video sensors for
monitoring activity
on city sidewalks
and public spaces
in cities around the world.
These video feeds are
analyzed in real time
based on computer
vision algorithms.
And they process activity
in the video frame
based on a set of predefined
classifiers established
through AI and
machine-learning algorithms.
Here's how a Placemeter
presents itself.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- If you could
measure urban areas
the same way you do with
page views on the web,
you'd have enough data
to make better decisions
about your community, meaning
stronger businesses, better
neighborhoods, and
more livable cities.
Placemeter does just that.
It's an urban
intelligence platform.
It processes videos from its
own easy-to-install sensor,
existing camera systems,
or even prerecorded video.
It analyzes pedestrian
and vehicular movements
and turns them into meaningful
data for municipalities
and businesses worldwide.
This way, retailers can optimize
storefronts and operations
for physical stores.
Commercial realtors
can provide clients
with solid proof and analysis
of foot traffic potential.
And municipalities
can make smarter
decisions with public money,
delivering better services
and safer streets to all.
Start quantifying your world
today at least placemeter.com.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Quantify your world
today for free--
at least the demo.
So in contrast to
Whyte's method, which
deploys time lapse
photography in attempt
to test the set of hypotheses
about how people inhabit
urban space, Placemeter
employs big data analytics
in an attempt to make
discoveries and derive
hypotheses from patterns
of movement and activity,
quantifying the life
of the street in terms
of a set of pre-established
classifiers.
Former editor in chief of
WIRED magazine Chris Anderson
has described this new
era of big data analytics
as, "a new era of
knowledge production
characterized by
the end of theory."
In other words,
big data analytics
enables an entirely new
epistemological approach
for making sense of the world.
Rather than testing
a theory by gathering
and analyzing relevant
data as Whyte did,
big data analytics
seems to gain insights
that are born from the data.
OK.
But what are big data?
Rob Kitchin, in his book
The Data Revolution,
identifies a series
of characteristics
which help frame it.
Big data are huge in volume.
They are high in velocity.
They are diverse in
a variety of type.
They are exhaustive in scope.
In other words,
you're not dealing
with a sample size of a subset.
But you're actually attempting
to get the entire population
as your data set.
They are fine grained
in resolution.
They are relational in nature.
And they are flexible, holding
the traits of extensionality
and scalability.
Now, currently, Place Lab
is being deployed in Paris
to study urban design proposals
for renovating urban traffic
services.
and traffic circles into more
pedestrian friendly zones
in the city.
They do things like
study how these park
benches are used or
not used, bike paths
widths, and so forth.
But this trend here is
toward instrumenting
physical environments
with sensors
and employing big data analytics
to quantify urban life in ways
that are characteristics of
many, many so-called smart city
initiatives, which we're
seeing pop up around the world.
From this Songdo International
Business District
in South Korea, also
known as New Songdo,
which is a new city built
from scratch by a partnership
between New York based
developer Gale International
and the New York office
of Kohn Pederson Fox,
as well as Cisco Systems, the
digital plumbers so to speak.
To Masdar City in the
United Arab Emirates
developed by the Mubadala
Development Company
in association with
British architecture firm
Foster and Partners.
To Hudson Yards in New
York, a partnership
between related companies Oxford
Properties and the New York
office of Kohn Pederson Fox.
I'd like to talk a little
bit about Hudson Yards.
When completed, this
$20 billion project
will span seven city blocks
on the west side of Manhattan.
It's literally the largest
real estate development project
ever undertaken in the US.
It will incorporate more
than 18 million square feet
of commercial and
residential space,
including 100 retail shops,
4,000 residences, and 14 acres
of parks and public plazas.
This massive development
effort promises
to showcase the latest smart
city technologies promising
the world's first connected,
responsive, clean, responsible,
reliable, and
efficient neighborhood.
Who wouldn't want that?
Who would want to
live in a dumb city?
The project also pretends
to be the world's
first quantified community, a
literal testbed for experiments
in urban data science led
by NYU's Center for Science
and Urban Progress, or CUSP.
Constantine Kontokosta,
CUSP's project leader,
describes the
quantified community
as a fully instrumented
urban neighborhood
that uses an integrated
expandable sensor
network to support the
measurement integration
and analysis of neighborhood
conditions, activity,
and outcome.
So they're doing things
like measuring, modeling,
and predicting pedestrian
flows, gauging air quality
both within buildings
and across open spaces,
measuring and modeling
energy production and usage
throughout the project,
measuring health and activity
levels of residents and
workers using a custom designed
opt-in mobile application.
Now, how many
people in this room
are familiar with the
Quantified Self movement?
Not many.
OK, few, few.
So the notion of a
quantified community
stems from the idea of the
Quantified Self, which simply
involves people
logging personal data
about their daily activities
using wearable sensors.
You might have heard the
device, a Fitbit, for example.
Apps such as fitness activity
trackers, for example,
monitor a range
of health factors,
heart rate, steps taken, floors
climbed, calories burned, even
sleep quality, and produce
representations of our progress
toward self-identified goals
that are shared and aggregated
through online portals.
Here, the notion is that through
the continuous self-monitoring
of physiological
condition, we can
bring about personal
behavioral change.
We can change our
behavior if we just
know enough in quantifiable
terms about what the data is.
Now, scaling this paradigm
to the neighborhood,
the quantified community
then is the idea
that continuous
monitoring of the built
environment, the status
of its technical systems,
and human activity all can be
fed back into that environment
to alter its future
performance and ultimately
the behavior of its inhabitants.
Here, people engaged
with their neighborhood
not only by consuming
its services
and administering
its systems, but also
by serving as sources of
measurable behavioral data.
People in this context
become censors.
They become,
themselves, censors.
And Shannon Mattern has
done some interesting work
on this, article
in Places journal
online recently,
actually about a year
ago now, where she identifies
some of the key problems here.
Yet, if we were to measure
the behavior of these citizen
sensors as an index of the
engagement with the city,
we find that their
actions, in fact,
are limited by the
instruments that
render those actions visible
and worth accounting for.
She references
Hannah Arendt here
in saying the trouble
with modern theories
of behavioralism--" this is
Arendt in 1958 in her book
The Human Condition-- "is
not that they are wrong
but that they could become true,
that the very instruments used
to measure behavior
are indicative of
and constitutive of
societies of automatism
and sterile passivity."
So the data that
we generate based
on determinist assumptions
and faulty methodologies
in some cases could
end up shaping
populations and building
worlds in their own image.
So the quantified
community at Hudson Yards
thus can be seen as a test
bed for future urban life
where urban intelligence,
the so-called smartness
of the smart city, is rendered
not as conscious liberal
or objective, but
rather as performative.
In the shift from observational
tools to environments
that observe, both the
city and its citizens
converge into populations of
human and non-human actors
and actants that comprise
not individual bodies
and personal experiences,
but rather patterns
of activity and behavior
iteratively mined
and interpreted by
algorithmic processes.
Now, this testbed
world of big data,
a world where correlation
supersedes causation,
is a probabilistic one where few
things are certain and most are
only probable, such as the
relationship between cheese
consumption and the
number of people being
tangled in their bedsheets.
It presents an
urban epistemology
that is not concerned
with documented facts
representing spaces or
making representative models
of our world, but rather
creating models that are in
and of themselves territories.
So the question
is what questions
do we need to be asking
about these new territories?
Dalton and Thatcher have
argued for a new field
of critical data studies that
situates these territories
in broader social, cultural,
and political contexts and that
address the technical, ethical,
political, and economic,
temporal, spatial, and
philosophical implications
of this shift from
observational tools
to observing environments.
And in closing, I'd like to
transpose their so-called five
questions at the
end of that essay.
to urban environments.
And in doing, so we might ask
what historical conditions have
led to the instrumentation of
cities with big data systems
and infrastructures?
How is big data being
deployed or employed
in the production of urban
space and infrastructure?
Who controls the production
and analysis of big data
in urban environments?
What implicit and
explicit biases, motives,
and imperatives
drive their work?
Who are the urban
subjects of big data?
And what new forms of
knowledge are they producing?
And ultimately, what
productive insights can
urban big data offer after all?
What other forms of knowledge
could it help to produce?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much for inviting
me, Liz and Becky and everyone
at the Radcliffe Institute.
I'm so happy to be
back at Radcliffe
as an undergraduate in the '70s.
And I'm going to be speaking
about a subject that is dear
to my heart, the maximum
city I call home, Bombay,
the mega city that was
renamed Mumbai in 1995
by the right-wing party,
Hindu party, Shiv Sena.
It's for that reason
that I'm going
to refer to it in my talk
as Bombay and not Mumbai.
It's a city which has a density
of more than 44,000 people
per kilometer and a population
of over 18 million, all of them
jammed-- all of us
jammed-- into an area that
is only 233 square miles.
They have written
screenplays set in the city
and directed two films,
a feature and a VR short,
where the city is
very much a character.
The way I've come to
know Bombay is not
through my screenplays
or my films,
but primarily through
the act of photography,
just me and my one camera.
I began shooting
the city in 1976.
And I haven't
stopped since then.
My photographic
journey began here
in Cambridge in 1976 with a
loan of $220 from my roommate
Cathy Dement, god
bless her always,
to buy my first camera, a
Nikkormat with a 50 millimeter
lens.
I worked with Steve Geovanis
in the music library.
He was a junior and a
stringer for The Boston Globe.
He taught me the basics of how
to shoot and develop and print.
Shortly after I got
my camera and lenses
and got my lessons from
Steve and prepared Cathy,
I took a leave of absence for
a semester and returned home.
Ostensibly, to spend a
semester photographing Bombay,
but in reality because I was
just desperately homesick.
My talk is going to be
more showing than telling,
because I believe that
the act of looking
is as good a way of knowing
a city as any other.
This was one of the photos I
took on that first trip home.
It's the gateway of India from
the sea lounge of the Taj Mahal
Hotel 32 years before
terrorists held
it hostage for five
extremely bloody brutal days.
Now, of course, there
can be no open windows,
because of security.
No matter how modern
an Indian city is,
there are never any boundaries
between inside and outside.
These horse carriages used
to be symbolic of the city.
Now, they are banned,
except for a few
who take tourists on rides,
much like New York City.
The lifeline of the
city, its local trains.
Though this was taken in 1976,
the tracks remain the same.
This building still exists
next to a train station.
Our neighborhood bar serving
moonshine, that is long gone.
In its place as a 35 story
building empty of residence,
like most of these
new buildings are
that are bought for investments.
Nobody lives in them.
Though this was taken
in 1976, many wells
still exist in the city.
Water is always a valuable
and scarce resource everywhere
in India.
This photograph
is the equivalent
of two kids riding a
camel down Mass Ave. They
are on one of the city's main
arterial roads, Marine Drive.
So when I returned
home, I also started
photographing my family, my
grandmother, my grandfather,
on his favorite trip, to get
his fountain pen repaired.
He always left a tip.
My neighbor across the way,
[? Yasmin ?] [? Irani ?]
studying on her balcony.
I call this photo,
Evenings at Cozy building.
This was where I grew
up in an extended family
and my parents still live.
This was a typical scene
at home every evening.
I call this photo
Streetside Services.
And this was actually
taken only last year.
This is a typist typing
out something for someone
on an actual manual typewriter.
And this is Streetside
Services from 1976.
A palmist reads someone's hand.
And behind him, a lawyer is in
his open-air office consulting.
Again, but this time more
recently, Bombay's famous road
Marine Drive lined with
art deco buildings.
And this was at a
public air show.
These were innocent times
when this gentleman could
be a security guard
at the airport
and I, as a skinny
19-year-old, could
be a security guard at
Harvard guarding the chemistry
labs at night.
Bombay is a city of
infinite variety of worlds
within worlds of
different classes,
communities, religions, rituals.
I grew up with girls who are
Christians, Jews, Hindus,
Muslims, Jains.
I was a Parsi
Zoroastrianism myself.
This is Sean Ma, the son and
my husband's college friend
[? Lang ?] Ma.
They live opposite the
Chinese temple of Bombay.
And we visit their home and the
temple every Chinese New Year.
Though I come from an
extremely collective society,
in my creative work,
I've always been
interested in the individual
within the collective,
like in this photo.
The women of the Red Light
District, Kamathipura.
The celebration the
city is most known for,
the Ganapati festival of the
much-beloved Hindu God Ganesh,
who is immersed in the sea.
Then in 1986, I
began my film journey
with my first screenplay I
ever wrote for the film Salaam
Bombay!, a collaboration
with my friend
also from Radcliffe, Mira Nair.
The film was about street
children in Bombay.
And I'm very proud of my
unique credit on that film,
screenwriter slash
still photographer.
This was taken at
an actor's workshop
we held before filming began.
This is Bernad,
a street kid, who
was then adopted by a
cinematographer Sandi Sissel.
Bernad moved to Los Angeles in
1992 and began living there.
He is married to a
wonderful Chinese lady.
And they have a
13-year-old daughter
who is a national level
competitive ice skater.
And Bernad has been living in
Hollywood for the past so many
years since 1992.
And he's been working
at, appropriately enough,
Panavision.
Time pass, a unique
Indian concept.
All these hundreds of
people have so much time
to pass that they
are all staring up
at us shooting on the
second floor of a building,
except there's nothing to see.
Because the set was boarded
up to keep sound out.
This is our sound man Neal
on location hard at work.
The gang of street
kids we hung out
with before wrote
the screenplay,
the boy on the right
looks like such a toughie.
But once his cap was off,
it was another story.
The boy touching
his bald head is
who inspired the main
character of the film.
He's the real
[NON-ENGLISH], the tea boy.
The Bombay film
industry was always
known for its elaborate
hand-painted [INAUDIBLE].
They don't exist anymore.
A famous artist M.F.
Hussain began his career
as a painter of
these [INAUDIBLE].
Two thespians enjoying a
well-deserved cup of tea
after a bout of artificial red.
Naseeruddin Shah and
Stellan Skarsgard
shooting for the film Perfect
Murder on the streets.
Bombay used to have glamorous
movie premieres in gorgeous art
deco movie theaters.
This was one of the last of
the grand premieres in the '80s
with a Navy band playing.
The star of the
film, [INAUDIBLE].
And the red carpet of
those days, where you could
be much closer to the action.
Ever since I was a waitress
at the Hong Kong Bar
and Restaurant here on Mass
Ave, I've always paid attention
to waiters and waitresses.
This photo and the next one,
taken more recently last year,
this was taken at
a film festival
after party in one of the
city's richest residences.
I imagine the
mistress of the house
instructed her staff to clean
up immediately any of her guests
dropped anything, even if it
was in the middle of the party.
A New Year's Eve
dance in the '80s,
again, Bombay's mosaic of
Christians, Paris, Sikhs,
all rocking and rolling.
Unfortunately, its cosmopolitan
character has since eroded.
Of all Indian cities, women
of freer and safer in Bombay
as you can see in this photo.
And the classic trope
all over the world
and particularly in India,
the loose women parting
with the cigarette and
smoking versus the goddess.
Bombay always been known
as the city by the sea.
Countless generations
of citizens, regardless
of cost, class, and community
have enjoyed the many sea
fronts that line our coasts.
Even if one lives
in the interiors
in the most overcrowded
of localities,
there's always the
sea to give relief.
This is about to
change forever thanks
to a misguided mega-project
to build a 12 lane
coastal road using public
funds that will only benefit
a small percentage of car
owners, a road that will damage
the environment and make the sea
a distant dream that once was.
My favorite bird, the smartest
as well, a Bombay crow.
Rear window in Bombay.
So that was Bombay then.
And I'm going to
show you Mumbai now.
I'm not going to speak, because
I'd like you to just look.
And I could we dim
the lights, please?
That's it thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you to all
three of our presenters
for their provocative and also
very compelling presentations.
And now, we'll try to
pull things together just
for a few minutes before we open
up the floor to your questions.
And it's actually not very
easy to pull things together.
Because on the one hand,
we have Heidi's work
and Sooni's, both
of which come out
of a very long relationship
with a particular place
and also using different media.
And not exclusively
for artistic purposes,
but certainly those
are among the purposes.
And then we have
Mark's work, which
shows how we can use the
same media or similar newer
media not in
representational modes,
but in modes that allow
us to mine data from them.
And Mark also observes
that what we see
is conditioned by
the lens that we use,
which in turn affects us.
So without getting
too tangled up
in the idea of new
technologies, I
wonder if we can somehow put
the two approaches together
in terms of what they yield.
So I would like to ask
each of our three speakers
to comment on the kinds of
knowledge and understanding
about urbanism today that
are produced by their work
and through what
artistic strategies
the particular power of your
medium shows change over time.
So that's my question
to each of you in turn.
And I don't know,
perhaps, you'd like to--
- Well, I haven't really
thought about it in those terms.
I think that the difference
between, I think,
the work actually that I'm
showing versus what you were
showing and also to a lesser
extent-- we have more in common
with what we're doing.
But I think that
it's interesting
that the data can show
maybe where these people go
and what spaces they inhabit.
Whereas, I'm interested in
how an individual relates to
and feels about their
environment and what
kind of personal
stories that they
create around a tactile space.
And it's funny, because
in Detroit, for example,
people always talk about the
emptiness, the empty spaces.
And we were sure in our film
to very rarely show just
an empty building on a street.
There was always a
person scurrying by
or someone in the window.
We even have a shot in the film
where a crane is taking down
all these houses as part of
the mayor's oath to the people
to tear down like 60,000
houses, unoccupied houses.
And we would be shooting that.
And then just one
street behind there
would be a little kid in the
window, maybe the last family
on the block.
And so there was
this push to shrink
the city while we were filming.
It was when Mayor Bing
was the Mayor of Detroit.
And it was all about
shrinking the city
and turning off street
lights and turning off
water and saving money.
And if there was only one person
on the block, they should move.
They should just move.
And that would be
more practical.
But there wasn't money
to give them to move.
And so it was like, what
makes a neighborhood?
I mean, there's
birds, and trees,
and grass, and stray dogs,
and maybe one old lady
on the block.
And what is her value?
And if there's only
one person interacting
with a space that was
made for multitudes,
does the value of
that space change?
And in the eyes of
the lady on the block,
it's her whole world.
It's her memories.
It's her life.
It's the smells and
sounds of her kids
who used to live there.
And so for her, it's a
hypertacile, real, living
thing.
It's her life.
It's her memory.
And to the city,
it's just a nuisance.
Because it wasn't
made just for her.
So these were the kind
of conversations that
were happening in the city.
And we tried to capture
in the way we could
through our lens, which
doesn't answer your question,
but it's an answer.
- Yeah.
OK.
Well, I'll take a crack
at trying to approach it.
I think the intention in
presenting the kind of talk
that I presented in
this milieu is really
to try to push back to some
of the overarching claims
that people working in this
field of, let's call it,
smart city development
make about what not only
the aspirations
are, but what are
some of the potential
capabilities are.
And I think that one of the
things that we are witnessing
as some of these
proposals, projects,
are moving from the
realm of speculation
to being built or enacted is
that the kind of territory
is shrinking in terms
of there's a kind of gap
between what something is being
projected to be capable of
and in fact what is being really
used for or is useful for.
And I think one of the things
that people are coming around
to is just this notion that
specifically this type of work,
this so-called small data,
is extremely valuable
to understand the
qualitative components
or the qualitative aspects
of an urban environment.
In looking at correlations
not caring about causation,
the idea is that you
would make discoveries,
that you would operate on--
I was having a
conversation last night
about people working with
the New York Public Library's
digital collection of menus
across hundreds of years.
Or, 100, 150 years,
I'm not quite sure.
But being able to look
and try to correlate
the presence of grapefruit
on a menu with, let's say,
droughts in California
or supply chain shifts
is the kind of question
that big data enables.
The problem is that
much like 20th century
kind of techno-determinism in
urban design in particular,
higher in design, there is
the drive that this empiricism
becomes totalizing.
And so in this
context, I think it's
important to be able to not
just look away or say this is
only quantitative information.
Cities are far more
complex and diverse.
They are filled with
non-addressable spaces, spaces
which aren't easily
quantifiable.
And within this context,
it's important to be
able to point to
examples where knowledge
of ways of knowing
the city exceed
the ability of any one media or
medium and any one discourse.
And so it's, in a sense,
what kinds of questions
do we need to ask from the
perspective of the humanities
to be able to engage
with what's ultimately
a fairly powerful force
and, to a certain extent,
beginning to drive decisions.
For example, in Detroit
about what parts of the city
do we reconfigure urban
services, street lights,
for example, water, electricity.
How can we input into this
policy-making, decision-making
process in ways which can
make qualitative difference?
- I've always found photography
as an ideal medium to document
change and preserve memories by
[INAUDIBLE] of things that are
disappearing.
And that's always
been my personal,
kind of, motivator to
photograph the city as well
as the community I belong to,
both of which are disappearing.
The city that I knew is
disappearing and the community
I belong to as well.
I was struck by the
images of Detroit.
And it's funny that it would
never happen in my city
that there would be spaces that
are kind of derelict and empty,
because it just doesn't happen.
There's not an inch of
empty space in Bombay.
And probably in
other Indian cities
as well, it's always
broken down to be built up.
Nobody leaves anything
derelict ever.
And so there's a lot
of churning going on
in Indian city,
especially Bombay.
Bombay is full of change now.
It's full of the mega
development projects.
They all involve corruption,
including public works.
And there are a lot
of active citizens
who are trying to
oppose it to, I'm
sorry to say,
little or no avail.
- We're almost at our
discussion period.
But I'm just going to take
the moderators prerogative
to ask Sooni one
more question, which
is that the beautiful
photographs that she showed
us were divided into two series,
as she herself specified,
A first earlier series
in black and white
and a second more
contemporary series filled
with the drama of color and
also with all kinds of contrasts
that speak to the
contemporary moment.
So I wanted to ask about
your different strategies
and whether you
consider it all one
body of work or several body.
- I don't know about
considering it one body work.
I think they're
two bodies of work.
The color is actually
a result of technology.
Most of these were
camera phone pictures.
And though I'm a purist,
I love the camera phone.
Because I always
have it with me.
And I always used
to resolve to carry
a camera with me every day,
but I never managed to.
And now, I always
have it with me.
And the other thing is I'm
a very avid Instagrammer.
Because when I
started photography,
there was of very few
avenues to share your work.
And when Instagram
came out and I
could share my work with
friends across the globe,
I completely dived into it.
I have some 3,000 plus
photos on Instagram,
including a lot of these.
So it's a question
of technology that
made the second body of work.
- Thank you.
All right.
So we'd like to give
you all a chance to ask
questions of our presenters.
As you can see, there's a mic in
the center of the aisle there.
And if you'd like
to ask a question,
please just come up to the mic.
If there are several of
you, you can stand in line.
And when it's your turn,
please identify yourself.
And please ask a question
along with making any comments.
So I know it's hard
to be the first one,
but I can't imagine
that some of you
don't have questions for
these amazing speakers.
- Can I go right ahead?
- Go for it.
- Well, this is a comment
and a question for Sooni.
When I was 12 or 13,
I was lucky enough
to capture or just flick the
channel and see Salaam Bombay!
And besides the commercials
there always were,
I was struck by your movie.
And it's been an
inspiration for me
since then to study cities
as a political science major,
to look at cities as a civic
space that's continuously
transforming.
And I thank you so
much for your art.
- Thank you so much.
- And I'm definitely going
to look for your Instagram.
Because I loved your writing
and your storytelling
and your photography.
And I want to continue that.
My question to you
is I'm Bangladeshi.
- Sorry?
- I'm Bangladeshi.
- Yeah.
- So three or four
years ago, I was
working with an NGO called BRAC
on water policy in Bangladesh.
And Dhaka has been
a city that has
changed within 10 to
20 years, 10 of which
I've never been back.
I was born in this country.
I consider myself an American.
But I have history and
roots that obviously go back
to being Bengali.
So I wonder when I was passing
through the city corporation
and seeing this tall
building, how people--
when growing up in
Cambridge and continuing
to live in Cambridge when
I can walk up to my city
councilor and say, can I
make officer hours with you?
Can I talk about a city
ordinance with you?
How do we bring that
with keeping in mind
the differences between
and the stereotypes that
are associated with
democracy and Westernization?
How do we bring that
kind of openness?
How do we bring that civic
conversation back to our people
and integrate our values
and culture and history
into what we can transform our
cities and our way of life?
Thank you.
- That's a good question.
I wish I had the answer.
- I just trying
to figure it out.
Yeah.
- I would love to know
the answer to that.
Because we had one
avenue in India
called the RTI Act, which
is Right To Information.
And now, the current government
wants to repeal that as well.
So nothing is public.
In my city, Bombay, they
will have a Development Act.
And they will do
it, and then they
will make it public for five
days of public comments.
And the act will have such
far reaching consequences.
And it would never happen
in any Western city,
but it happens
constantly in India.
Because there's
no accountability.
There's no feeling that they
are accountable to the public.
Politicians feel that they
are almost like royalty.
Nobody can question them.
And there's a huge
amount of corruption
involved in all these projects
and all these public projects.
So I'm sorry to be so
pessimistic about it,
but realistically
speaking I don't know when
it's going to change really.
And what I talked about,
this coastal road,
we tried very hard, but
we didn't get anywhere
unfortunately.
- Well, thank you anyway.
- And thank you for your kind
words about Salaam Bombay!
- Of course.
- Thank you so much.
I have a query
beginning with Mark.
In your comment about
empiricism becoming totalizing
and, I think in your
engagement, there
is a deep yearning for
the non-totalitarian
and the creative.
So it is in that spirit, the
discourse of this smart city,
how does it cultivate the reason
and practice of soul city?
And I'm here reminded of the
great work of anthropologist
Ulf Hannerz who nearly
50 years ago wrote
a book called The Soulside.
So how do we think of the
[INAUDIBLE] space, this sphere
of this soul sphere as well?
My connected query to
both Heidi and Sooni is--
thank you so much--
among your many
important engagement,
one dimension is the engagement
with loss and disappearance,
and therefore ways
of knowing the city,
especially when Sooni,
you make the comment,
"seeing is a way of knowing."
But that act of seeing,
does it also involve
an act of weeping or crying?
Therefore, I think
with the theme
of loss and
disappearance, how do
we bring weeping as a way of
knowing which then becomes
a companion to solidarity.
Therefore, the
question would be that
what is this base of
hope in this context?
And how do we think
of the city space
in terms of poetics of space,
but also the emergent spaces
of hope?
- If I can just take
the first question--
can you just repeat the author?
I'm not sure I'm
familiar with this text.
- He's an anthropologist.
His name Ulf Hannerz,
originally from Sweden
who did fieldwork with, I think,
an Afro-American community
in Washington DC.
But I am just reminded
of the title Soulside.
- Soulside.
- Just to bring the connection
of this soul sphere,
because in my work,
I'm also trying to--
I'm coming from India with of
kind of, as Sunni mentioned,
the regal discourse
of the smart city.
So we need to bring a
discourse of the soul city.
- Sure.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
There's a couple of ways
one can respond to that
or people have
responded to that.
One is to say simply that
this soul side of the city
is a non-addressable space.
At least, it's not
addressable in the sense
that it doesn't
have an IP address.
The soul doesn't have
an IP address, right?
And to a certain extent,
one finds that response
unsatisfying.
Another way of approaching,
responding to that,
is to suggest in a similar
way that we were talking about
this morning where
people moved to the city,
and it changes them.
Their attitudes change.
Their values change
in some respects
or at least grow and develop.
And I think back to
Martin Heidegger's essay
on "The Age of the
World Picture."
And he's talking about
this quantification.
In the age of the world picture,
the certain move or shift
toward a degree of,
shall I say, bigness
moves over from the
quantitative to begin to have
a qualitative component to it.
It has a quality to it, right?
And he describes this as
a kind of modern condition
and as a result
from a whole range
of technological developments.
Similar claims are
being made about how--
and this is the kind of
darker side in a sense of some
of the propositions--
Chris Anderson's
claim of the end
of theory, where correlation
supersedes causation.
We're talking
about a different--
in the sciences, in
the hard sciences,
it's not such a leap
to say we don't really
care why this is happening.
But we can show you
evidentiary data that
prove this correlation exists.
When we're talking
about the soul side,
it's a question of has
that quality, which
comes from a quantitative
condition being
pushed to a certain scale,
already become part of us?
And I think that's
the challenge.
That's what we're looking at.
- I think it's so
evocative, the concept
of weeping and acknowledging
the loss of what
was no longer coming
back and that there
is a crying and a
weeping that I think
you could feel in some of the
clips that I showed today.
You know, spaces matter.
And neighborhoods matter.
And where things
take place matters,
especially in a city
like Detroit, which
not unlike what Angela was
mentioning about Los Angeles,
the highways, the freeways, the
way they were built in Detroit
also completely segregated
blacks from whites in Detroit.
It was intentional.
It was done.
The concept in mind was to
just keep everyone apart.
And it's very, very hard to
undo an infrastructure like that
even with good intentions.
The city planning was
done a certain way.
And that has not been resolved.
So when we talk about all
the development happening
in this one area,
now they call it
Midtown, that is easily
accessible by suburban people.
So they come in to the
Tigers games on the weekends.
They'll come to the opera.
They'll go to the Detroit
Institute of Arts.
They'll go to these places.
It's easy to get there.
There's parking.
And for a lot of
black residents who
live in the Greater
Detroit City, which
is a huge massive place,
it's not convenient.
It's expensive.
They don't feel comfortable.
All the development and
all of the new residents
are mostly white.
So in a way, it's
like recreating
the problem that was never
solved the first time around.
And so I think that in order
to help bridge this divide,
they should start with the
spaces that events are held in.
There is a lot of foundations
right now in Detroit,
sort of NGO-type money
flowing into the city.
And always, when you're
invited to an event,
it happens at the
Detroit Institute of Art
or it happens at the Masonic
Temple or a known space
in this Midtown
area, because they
think it's going to be
convenient to those people
interested.
If they move those
events and said
I'm doing it at Baker's
Keyboard Lounge, completely
the other side of
town, or I'm doing it
at the raven on the East
Side on Chene Street
and you partnered with these
older black local businesses
that have credibility
with their neighborhoods,
if they work together
to get the word out
that there's going to be
meetings in unexpected places
and vice versa, I think that
that would go a long way
to the longtime residents
feeling left out
of this new Detroit and
cut out and forgotten.
It makes people feel
useless and disrespected.
And also, there's
this sense of history
that this racial divide is
just being recreated again.
So I actually really think
some of these changes
have to happen with where
events and invitations are
made in Detroit.
It's that simple.
And that has not even been done.
I mean, that's how
basic we're talking.
- I'm going to answer
your question about hope.
There's certainly no
hope for the politicians.
But I have a lot
of hope, because
of what I've seen with the
people of the city, of my city,
when there are disasters like
floods, how people react.
You know, you must have
seen in these photographs
a woman who has no home who
has everything outdoors,
and she's still smiling.
That's what gives me hope.
It gives me hope that
people who have nothing
still continue to smile and
still continue to have hope.
And that's an amazing thing.
And that exists in the city.
And that, I think,
nobody can destroy.
And the other hope
of the city is
people are constantly coming
to the city, because for them
the city represents
hope as opposed
to villages where
they are starving.
And they say that nobody
starves in the city.
I'm not sure how true that is.
But that's what they say.
- Thank you.
- Hi, my name is [? Palavi ?]
[? Mondi. ?] I'm a Loeb Fellow
at the Graduate School
of Design this year.
Otherwise, I reside in the
world of cities and water,
be it climate change
or restoration
or [INAUDIBLE] systems.
So having follow
some of your work--
Sooni, I've obviously
seen the film--
I'm very intrigued by the
dystropic view of Detroit.
And I've only anecdotally
heard a lot around water
infrastructure and
how that intersects
with issues of people
living and the community.
The real estate
interests sort of giving
this brand of the Renaissance
and the white flight
into Detroit and really
issues around accountability
and how we actually ensure
that what happened in Flint
doesn't become a phenomenon
that a lot of cities in the US
are just waiting to witness.
So my question
really is if I ground
this discourse in the
field of resilience--
which is also becoming a
very hot discourse area
and how it intersects
with urbanism.
Sooni, since you mentioned
Mumbai and the opportunities
even though there's no physical
space for these opportunities
to play out in a conventional
sort of design, architecture,
or urbanism standpoint, I
wonder how we as a community,
looking at cities from different
expertise or disciplines,
how we want to acknowledge
the opportunity
to tell the stories
that need to be told,
sort of represent
realities in ways
that are not convenient or even
for that matter constructive?
And I really want to
open it up to whoever
wants to take a pass at how
can we tell the stories.
Not to just sort of make the
world be aware of realities,
but address it in a way
that's universally applicable,
but also challenging for
this discourse to inform us
in how we want to move forward.
- Well, if I
understood correctly,
it's always a
documentary's-- you know,
we're often asked to be also
activists and to use our work
for a specific purpose.
And we've always sort of
evaded sort of the agenda film
and tying our movies
in a bow at the end.
There's a whole trend of
documentary filmmaking
where at the end
it's like, if you
want to help, turn off your
faucet and turn off your light.
These are the things you can do.
Go to this website,
and you can--
and I think that's great.
Our work's never fit
into those boxes.
So sometimes we do reveal
inconvenient truths
and don't offer solutions,
which can frustrate people.
But what I think is
really important,
at least in my
medium, is to partner
with organizations that have
the will and the resources
to make a curriculum.
For example, several
of my films are taught
in schools and universities.
And we helped make a curriculum
or made it easy for people
to make a curriculum in
Canada and elsewhere.
How do we teach this film?
How do we make your
film or your photograph
into a tool for other people
who do have ideas, solutions,
and agendas?
So, for example, I made a
film called 12 & Delaware
about the abortion battle--
it's on HBO this film--
raging on a street corner
in Fort Pierce, Florida.
So on one side of the street,
there's an abortion clinic.
On the other side
of the street, there
is a crisis pregnancy
center, which is basically
a fake abortion clinic.
Women think they're
in an abortion clinic,
because they're getting
a free pregnancy test.
But it's actually
a pro-life front
where they will give an
ultrasound to the girl
and tell her she'll get breast
cancer if she has an abortion
or tell her that she's not
as far along as she is.
So by the time she
figures it out,
it's too late to get an
abortion in her state.
So we got inside this crisis
pregnancy center and filmed.
And then we got inside
the abortion clinic.
And it's a character-driven film
about this one street corner
and the battle, the
abortion battle.
Now, what we've done with that
film is when we were finished
with it, we've allowed
NARAL and Planned Parenthood
to use it for other events.
And as long as we don't
have great disagreements
with what they're doing with the
film, we happily hand it over.
So I think that that is really
how we can get our messages out
and also interpreted
by different people
in different ways, so that you
can actually reach more people
and start using our work
for more concrete solutions.
- As one filmmaker said, if
you want to send a message,
go to UPS or FedEx.
And so I kind of agree with
that and kind of don't.
Because after we
made Salaam Bombay!,
we started an organization
for street kids
called Salaam Trust that
is still very active
I don't know how
many years later.
I think film is an easier
way to be an activist
than a still photographer.
There have been
still photographers
who have been activists and
who've been working for change.
But I don't think that
is my primary goal when
I take photographs.
I take photographs, because I'm
just obsessive about putting
frames around reality.
I don't know why.
I think I was born like that.
But in the films
that I make, there's
definitely some food
for thought and hope
that things will change.
- So we have one minute left.
But these two people have been
very patiently standing online.
Is there is there a way
for you to very quickly ask
your question?
- I mean, I can ask
it as fast as I can.
- Yeah, as fast as
you possibly can.
- Sure.
Hi, thank you so much
for sharing your work.
My question is about nostalgia.
I think in the films, it's very
clear when nostalgia comes up.
I think with data,
it's less clear.
I'm interested in how data
talks about nostalgia.
Does data talk about nostalgia?
And I'm also curious
when we change
cities, when we try
to be purposeful about
change, how do we use nostalgia?
Is it useful?
And whose nostalgia do we use?
- In one minute.
Well, that's a great question.
It's characteristic of the kinds
of more interesting questions
that are being asked
about data today.
And I guess the one
thing I could say
is that nostalgia
is being looked at.
But it's more how can
data and analytics operate
on the objects of nostalgia?
So it would be about
archives, looking at archives.
And to what extent can it
reveal something or discover
correlations or relationships
which we don't already
know about nostalgia--
in one minute.
- OK.
Were you-- did you
have more to say?
- No.
I was not--
- If you can quantify nostalgia
with data, I mean, call me.
I'd love to see that.
I mean, I thought it
was interesting actually
looking at Angela's streetcar
map versus the subway map.
Something about
that, seeing them
next to each other and all
that was lost when the street
cars were removed from
those black neighborhoods,
I actually surprisingly
found that effective.
And that was just a graph.
So, actually, I
think it's intriguing
the idea that you can move
people emotionally with data.
I think that's an
interesting Area
- But I would also like to
conclude with an argument
for a very small data.
Because humanists are very
good at close reading.
And so Heidi and I were
speaking about the title
of her film, Detropia.
And for me, there are
all these associations
that come out of just that one
term, like utopia, dystopia,
cornucopia, detritus,
deteriorate, -opia,
hope, and I suppose
nostalgia as well.
But so it feels as
though somehow our task
is to balance vast sort of even
unimaginable quantities of data
along with the incredible
importance of very
small things.
So let's conclude on that.
Thank you to our
three presenters
for their wonderful talks.
And thank you to you
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]